In this episode, we're going to build a reddit style upvoting, downvoting system using angular
form firebase.
In this example, we have a collection of items already in the database, and we also have
firebase authentication setup in our app.
If you're new to firebase authentication, I've added a couple links in the description
with more details.
The first thing we need to think about is modeling our data in the firebase, no SQL database.
Our database needs to answer two fundamental questions.
What is the user's vote for a given item, and what's the total vote count for a given item?
We can answer this question by creating a collection based on the unique idea of the items.
For each item ID, we save the user IDs that have voted on that item.
This way we can query an item and see if the user's voted on it, and we can also tally
up the collection of users under an item to get the total vote count.
Let's start by building the service.
The first thing we need is the firebase object observable for a specific item ID.
We also need the user to be able to cast the vote by updating the item object in the database.
The update user vote function will send a new key value pair to the...